London loves mediocre Minshew oh god no  min she was so brexit who knows my back  I'm more than me I wish someone could  relate well well how did I handle being  hurt well you stole my city start by  hunting in prayer of course you just got  to relax not listen to local talk radio  and guys you gotta crush that you're not  gonna replace me Brendan Island is it  Brendan is it Brandon I replaced my  backup no problem see ah look it's a  tense time for everyone round the daters  have been one how dare you ask me Dad  about crap no no I asked if he had a  message for the team not a question but  the way you hand the bottom of Caffrey  is amazing yeah I wouldn't rush back me  take that why do they catch up for him  my picnic energy back to me wanna do  fall yeah we're all gonna start again  I'm Milla and lately I've had some time  to learn about the Internet you can  subscribe below  whatever that means here let me tap in a  Eli man oh no